okey it's not quite swarm Lake but this  frozen landscape in the Russian Arctic  is home to a rare and remarkable being  distinguishable by their bathing suits  in sub-zero conditions apparently  oblivious to the bitter cold they call  themselves the walruses they might just  be the world's brief a swimming Club  I feel like I have been reborn it's a  great feeling  simply wonderful we do it for bigger  extreme conditions are good we are  extreme it makes me happy I respect  myself  I can't do this  Alina has been swimming here since she  was 7 years old  she does this right through the depths  of the Arctic winter sure sure  everything is very good I feel stronger  a lot of emotions positive emotions no  game on see and then she showed me to  the changing Hut and told me not to be  afraid  I have a good friend here Vladimir  Ivanovich he was a champion cold water  swimmer and he was going to show me how  to do this  I became a Katy Stallard Sky News  Murmansk